well from a hot holiday looks to Hot
Holiday toys Mercedes checks in with an
expert for a look at this season's
must-haves
let's talk the hottest toys for the
holiday season and there was no one else
I trust to tell us about toys than our
very own Chief toy officer from the toy
Insider it's Lori shot hi Lori hi I'm so
excited to be here and share some of my
very favorite toys and the hottest toys
this holiday season so you want to jump
right in and talk about
squishmallows they are seriously the
hottest toy they are flying off shelves
and I'm so glad that they are at the top
of your list they really are and it's
it's I'm showing it to you so if you see
it buy it because they are really hard
to find so there's all kinds there's
holiday theme ones food Squad ones they
come in eight inch and 16 inch and
they're adorable this cocoa melon is
always a hit with the little ones and
what do you have that has to do with
Coca melon so this is our Coco melon
ultimate learning bus two modes of play
music and learning and I love this now
if you have a little one in your house
you know who Coco melon is
absolutely when we push our buttons we
have learning but
we also have songs that kids and
grown-ups know and it also comes with
the Sorting pieces so kids can sort it
really is just fabulous
can we talk about an old classic that I
actually I have here and I I used to
play with trucks as a kid all the time
the classics called the truck it is it
is not only is it a classic it's
celebrating its 75th anniversary and
sort of as a nod to The Originals
they've come out with a limited series
of trucks that look just like the
original they are all Tonka tuck
um they're really cool of course our
truck works we can push it back we have
these nice big sturdy Wheels there's no
batteries no charges this is all kid
powered it tells us about what is big as
far as bikes go this year so Schwinn
makes these great bikes 16 and 20 inches
and I agree that it's probably one of
the best gifts you can ever give a child
because when you give it to them when
they're young they're going to grow up
with this so this is their Evo crate
line and I love it they are lighter
bikes they are single gear back pedal to
break so really simple for kids as young
as five to ride the handles are a little
bit smaller the seats a little bit
smaller really makes it a comfortable
ride for the kids let's talk about this
Crystal Ball you have in front of you
what is that so magic mixes so this
Crystal Bowl fills up with this fog and
then we're waiting we say the magical
words magical mixes
magical Mixie creature
so there's over 80 different sounds and
reactions and this beautiful myth so
kids can play with four different modes
with their magical mixing new Beyblade
burst battle your friends on two levels
so I have the Beyblade burst quadrive
but there's also the interstellar Drive
the interstellar drop and that is my
favorite one of the season so it's
actually two levels of play so kids are
huge fans of Beyblade and not just kids
by the way because there's a lot of
parents that have grown up with this and
they love these battling tops but these
new Arenas are really what's making the
difference on the interstellar draft the
um the actual blades the tops they're
spinning they're battling they can stay
on the top level there's a middle piece
that you can flip making it a little
more challenging or you take that middle
piece out and the battling tops will
start on top all down to the first level
and continue the battle Lauren you
always all have your finger on the pole
of what is hot if you want more
information what's your website
toyinsider.com
[Music]